[Music]
[Laughter]
congratulations is brought to you by the
cash what's up babies congratulations
the podcast episode 107 and we're in it
and also I'm wearing tan and also I have
a tan background
I haven't get rid of wrote you know
brought to my attention maybe it's a
[ __ ] you know mate he's like maybe
you should change your shirt you know
and he gave me a suggestion and I was
like you know what dude you gotta be raw
you got to be real you got to come and
you got to do it as you are do it it's
like that song and Nirvana song come as
you are dude you come as you are I ain't
changing for nobody now that's not
actually don't like when people say that
kind of [ __ ] I ain't change it for
nobody it's like a very 26 year old
mentality you can't be [ __ ] almost 40
and say I don't like changing I ain't
changing but yeah we're live on the app
on my app if you go into the App Store
and you can just watch the podcast on on
my app crystally after typing kris the
other apps or and you will see the first
10 minutes 15 minutes before anyone else
live and if I goo if I goof you know
what I mean but I gotta say man I'm
wearing tan and it's a tan background
and that's what's up and that's what's
up this week that's what's gonna be
what's up with this week but I got shows
in Seattle coming up there's still a
little tickets left on my Saturday show
we added that recently and then I'm
going to Spokane those are all sold out
because probably cuz snuffing doing
spoke and also take the e off the end of
that [ __ ] City so it can just be
spoke Spokane and people want say
Spokane and you won't have to get mad
it because people hate when you say
Spokane mm-hmm but anyway it's episode
107 and I can't believe we're doing it
and we got a guest coming up we got our
first guest confirmed
besides my brother or as my mom would
say for some reason bralla she says that
sometimes and instead of San Diego she
says San Diego as a to be to be funny
now she's a crazy person she also calls
me brother maffei and meet crinks for
some reason and i don't know why but
whatever we're gonna you know she's 70
and she just people just get crazy as
they get older they get so much like
themselves they can't they can't handle
it that's that's why you basically are
an actor in a movie you become an actor
in a movie that is undirected that's
what you become it's like it's like when
when when Denzel or Al Pacino is in a
movie with some young director that has
no vision and they're just like oh I'm
gonna walk all over them that's what
your [ __ ] mom and dad become and then
you're like al do you maybe want to do
it a different way and he goes like this
I've been in this business for a long
time no and then it just like okay and
then he just walks all over him and then
Al Pacino as one of the worst
performances that he's ever had in his
career so basically your parents become
someone who are if you don't direct them
enough they will be the worst they will
be performing the worst in their entire
lives so my mom it's a San Diego and
that don't correct her but also it's
funny so my mom is basically Al Pacino
as well I'm second but oh I have been on
I've been home this past week which is
feeling like happening it's happening
less and less frequent I enjoyed my time
home in Los Angeles and I got some heavy
Road dates coming up soon which is just
a lot
I might have to turn down some [ __ ]
gigs that this college gig it's hard to
turn down work man but I want to be home
sometimes you know hmm I got into the
show the assassination of Gianni Versace
god what an Italian name Jenna Versace
and it's an I didn't even realize it
wasn't
in crime story because I saw the oj1 mmm
as good as a Kubla Gooding jr. Cuba
Gooding jr. is and that guy is a [ __ ]
amazing actor he really is I worked with
him it's a [ __ ] but I did and he's just
great um I did a movie with him two
years ago that hasn't come out yet and
he got a call in the middle this is how
good of a [ __ ] guy professional and
actor he is in the middle of acting in
this scene he got a call and his dad
died this is real and they were like do
you want to go oh do you need to fly
home and he was like nope I want to
finish the scene he was finishing it
wasn't even on his coverage he stayed to
be off-camera for us we were like dude
just go home fly home and he was like
nah do it he [ __ ] took a 20 minute
cry break and then came back and [ __ ]
killed it for us the guy is unbelievable
and he's a great actor and he won the
Oscar and he deserved it and he was
great in oj but also i thought it was
really weird
look he's such a good actor but the the
the OJ Simpson would just bogey is like
such a big guy you know it was weird to
pick up such a small guy Cuba Gooding
jr. to be a OJ it was just kind of
miscast
and as good as a Cuba Gooding jr. is
it's just I wanted some big [ __ ] wolf
to plate Oh J anyway fine I watched some
of the oj stuff you know the [ __ ]
Versace the this show I know I'm late to
the game by the way is blowing my mind
it's so good it's so good this
assassination American crime story
season 2 assassination of Gianni Versace
is so good everybody's so good in it the
tone is so good the writing the acting
is just amazing dude the guy who plays
Gianni Versace first of all it looks
just like him
he's so good dude I don't even know what
is that guy who is that guy I see him he
definitely played a
bad guy in James Bond no doubt there's
no way that guy did not play a bad guy
in James Bond um and I he was on a plane
with me once and I saw him and I was
like oh that guy either that guy that
guy is for sure who who is he what's his
name yeah that's him that's him
Edgar Edgar Ramirez how did they make
him look so much like jenna Versace how
did they make him look so much like you
Jennifer's hacci but um God he's good so
but Darren Criss is so good and I'm like
watching this show and I'm like this
this this [ __ ] guy's so good and then
I look it up and here's how dumb and out
of the loop I am I'm like why is nobody
talking about this and I look it up the
guy won like every award oh my god but
it's cool when Hollywood get some [ __ ]
right you know God that guy's a [ __ ]
good actor Darren Criss and so so is the
edgar some you know what he was at the
Comedy Store the other night Edgar
Ramirez [ __ ] I didn't know he should
have said something
he's so good they're all good everybody
in the show is good from the guy playing
the military guy to the other guy
playing his gay lover to the guy playing
the [ __ ] you got to watch his show
man if you haven't seen it Ricky Martin
is [ __ ] good which I was like what I
didn't know he was an actor I just
thought he [ __ ] lived la vida loca I
just thought I literally thought Ricky
Martin did pop music and then just was
like livin la vida loca from then on and
didn't do like he's good as [ __ ] though
he plays Gianni Versace's dead his gay
lover dead lover what you know anyway
it's he's the whole show so [ __ ] good
man you gotta watch his show um Finn
what's it was that guy Finn with wick
Whitlock wit wit [ __ ] wit rock he's
really good this guy what's he in God
he's good
these [ __ ] guys are good unbroken the
big short these guys always an American
Horror Story yeah Ryan Murphy raises all
these guys I love when they do that [ __ ]
I need to get in a camp dude I need to
get in a [ __ ] camp man god I got to
get in some [ __ ] cool camp I got to
create a camp they can't buy have his
[ __ ] Bryan Callen and Theo and
[ __ ] you know what I mean these
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] I got to get some
[ __ ] guys who just lose themselves in
a roll you know what I mean
that's so corny though it's not though
if they do it right you know like this
show he's just good man he's they're
good that makes me so mad when my dog's
bark I can't even get over it I know you
probably can't hear it in my thing but
my dogs are barking and it makes me so
angry dude I want them to know not to
bark and they should know not to bark
and they do know not to bark but they
[ __ ] do it anyway they do it anyway
if they hear the gardener a gardener a
neighbor [ __ ] the mailman could drive
by the [ __ ] if the fridge could make
a whirring sound and my dog's [ __ ]
bark and I'm angry and that's it I'm
[ __ ] angry where's the timer I don't
see it it's [ __ ] it it did the
[ __ ] barks my dog dude dude my dogs
dude
Sam specifically just all day [ __ ]
long they got the haircut they're cute
as [ __ ] dude dogs are amazing but they
bark these [ __ ] little [ __ ] bark so
much man stop Barkin I go no I go like
that and they go like this they know
what's up dude they're getting good at
[ __ ] outside though man the cue man
Sam and butters they're cute
anyway person Versace's clothing you
know Versace Versace is clothing is just
like to me uh mass I mean dude so much
the only thing I know about Versace is
that gold [ __ ] actually some of its
cool like that's cool this stuff that
future wears like rappers and stuff
sometimes it's cool oh that's not future
that's 2 Chainz um but like Versace like
the this stuff that like Persians wear
is just ridiculous like that gold
[ __ ] what is that gold uh what do we
call it like what would like him it
looks like what is that what would you
even call it you know you call it
Persian that's what you call it
that's the straight-up most Persian [ __ ]
you cuz where is that gold Versace like
who do we think we are you know that
you'd wear that you know who do we think
we are that you would get a gold
hibiscus print ah
click on it don't click off it cuz I'm
talking about it one fire and angry he
cooks off it when I start talking about
it anger Gold hibiscus print zipped
hoodie for $1,400
dude who do we think we are to get that
and wear that or the robes you know if
you lounge around in a robe let me add
let me just say this do it if you lounge
around in a robe and you're a guy who
the [ __ ] do you think you are if you're
just chilling with a robe on like and
postmates scum and you go get it get it
in your robe and you're just especially
if you're just you have like a two
bedroom a house like go [ __ ] yourself
you need to be so high up in the sky in
a [ __ ] condo with rooms and rooms and
marble and so much marble to wear a
goddam robe of any kind I don't care if
you get it from Bed Bath and Beyond if
you're wearing a row
an apartment complex in the valley in
Studio City you really got to rethink
what the [ __ ] going on
take it off close it up
shrug your shoulders back let it fall
and put on some [ __ ] pants man who
are you James [ __ ] Brown if you have
a robe on right now and you're listening
to this podcast and you're a man and you
make less than sixty million dollars a
year take it off take it the [ __ ] off
how much of these fashion guys are just
taking the piss out of everybody I'm
looking at some [ __ ] Versace shorts
that save room on it they save room on
it God look at these dumb [ __ ] models
look at these dumb do you have to be to
be a male model by the way not a female
my female models you can do it and turn
it into a brand and you could be smart
if you're a guy model
you're a [ __ ] dump you're a chair
dude you're basically a chair that's
what you are if you're a guy model this
is what you do sometimes you go you go
like this literally you go like this ah
you do that
where's I'm in that you do that that's
if you do if you're a [ __ ] male model
you go like this wait of what that's
what you do a lot you go like this you
say you say who's the president you say
stuff like this you say I'll [ __ ] I'm
real bad at math when when somebody says
what's 9 plus 4 you know dude you don't
know what a square root is you don't
need to though congratulations if you
don't know what a square root is I wish
I didn't know what a square root is [ __ ]
math dude dude once I got when I was in
I was in high school with we got two
imaginary numbers I go like this it
might have to go like this imaginary
numbers if they know why are we a math
it's hard enough why are we imagining
more [ __ ] that doesn't exist [ __ ] you
math teacher dude
I was so bad at math you know why I'm so
bad at math cuz who gives a [ __ ] dude if
you're not gonna be a man dude high
school is if you're listening to this
and you're in high school I guess
continue to go but it needs to be more
specialized man it needs to be more
specialized I got to go and learn a
[ __ ] home a Qui
dude why I don't want to do that [ __ ] I
got to learn a math why I'm a [ __ ]
comedian I knew I wanted to be comedian
why don't have to do math why to fall
back on what dude guess what guess who
still sucks at math hi
guess who still sucks at math me I suck
at math dude I barely know what a
[ __ ] square root is I'm a male model
when it comes to math dude sit on me sit
on me hot girl on the male model when it
comes to math you want me to add digits
hey hot girl sit on me bro you hey yo
you want me to [ __ ] add digits well
guess what dude instead third you want
me to [ __ ] male model bro
get out of here instead you want me to
add digits bro
[ __ ] off bro [ __ ] off god I hated when
high school when they made you do all
that [ __ ] dude
I'm oh I'm 38 and I'm still mad about
this [ __ ] you want me to you want me to
divide and do square roots and come up
with what trains gonna get to what stop
first dude I got some [ __ ] news for
you man go faster
oh I'll wait I'll wait dude this is the
real deal where's the [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
dude wow that sounds good you want me to
[ __ ] dude hey I got news for you my
camera rollers of ridiculous pictures of
my ceiling right now
but you got I got news for you dude you
want me to do the square root of [ __ ]
some [ __ ] you want me to [ __ ] with
imaginary numbers dude I got some
[ __ ] news for you that's who I am man
I'll look over my shoulder and dude I'm
not doing it man no no I'm not doing it
what I'm going to science class why to
learn chemistry I got news for you
hey get behind me check out this
shoulder look that's it dude I wish
these existed when I was in high school
I would [ __ ] do that anytime a
teacher
any time a teacher asked me [ __ ] the
square root of 75 that's what I do I go
I have it I have it I'd even go for that
I'd be like teacher I have it the Chris
and I'd be like what I'm a [ __ ] male
model in this [ __ ] we feelin [ __ ]
crazy today man we put the [ __ ]
creamer in the iced coffee what we put
the creamer in the iced coffee
what's a richer sound than that you're
the condo way high up above the clouds
and you've got a verse a regular Versace
row or a regular robe or a Versace robot
and you're like and the guy buzzes up
and then they come to meet you and
you're just hello okay because I damn
dude if I get more numbers from Burbank
calling me dude
hey Burbank never call me nobody in
Burbank better ever call me but imagine
having a meeting and you show up way
high up in the [ __ ] condos and the
guy's in a robe and then he's hey I'd
like to talk to you about some stuff
you'd be like I'm in for a [ __ ] bomb
in for the real deal dude I am in for
the real [ __ ] deal
it's so [ __ ] British to have ice in
your yes I'd like to talk to you a
little bit about an opportunity I have
an opportunity for you you'd be like is
it [ __ ] evil
it's not necessarily evil but some
people say hey listen nobody thinks
they're evil right we're all doing what
we think is right but people want
different things don't they
I'd like to talk to you a little bit
about something sure some people will
die but it is for the greater good right
I need your expertise oh my god that's
the most British thing you could
possibly hear right here I need your
expertise Wow dude I'm a [ __ ] idiot
why do you listen his podcast yeah
anyway dude but that's that's what's up
I so watch the versace and then don't
[ __ ] stop doing so much math when
you're 16 are you crazy bro are you
[ __ ] insane um I want to talk about
this [ __ ] YouTube video that was Ben
that had been brought to my attention
for the first time in years and it has
not gotten the recognition it deserves I
talked about it
alright ai-ai-ai-aight heard it first
years ago I watched it years ago it's
got a million views and let me tell you
something dude that is not enough that
is not enough because this is so funny
and I'm gonna play it for you guys and
first let me give you some background so
so George Brett is a [ __ ] uh-oh -
alright you know what I'm gonna do ad
brakes and then I'm gonna [ __ ] do
this right here alright there's two here
really okay cool me undies oh look look
hey look my favorite underwears period
Valentine's Day is right around the
corner rather than spending all the
money going out to fancy restaurants
just hanging your underwear all night
courtesy of me undies that's what I'm
gonna do
that's what I'm gonna do me undies uses
the coveted micro modal fabric which is
three times softer than cotton the
fabric genuinely feels like actual
heaven against your skin it really does
and when you're with your girl you can
put their stuff on and you have she can
wear her stuff you could wear your stuff
and you hug and it feels like I haven't
do it it's amazing it's the best feeling
in your heart and on your skin is
basically but you can get that style
perfectly suited for you men and women
can choose each from four different cuts
all of which are available from classic
colors too adventurous prints you know I
got I got my favorite are the are the
regular ones because they go with
everything I got my black ones on right
now
but speaking of prints this vide a
season me undies will be releasing a new
print every Tuesday that means you and
your loved one can chill in matching
prints for v-day and play the game of
how long can we keep these on dude it's
cute you don't need to go out and do all
that stuff be cute she'll love you more
for this me undies has a great offer for
my listeners for any first-time
purchasers when you order me undies you
get 15% off and free shipping this is a
no-brainer you get 15% off a pair the
most comfortable undies you will ever
put on to get your 15% off your first
pair free shipping and on two percent
satisfaction guarantee go to my undies
comm slash Congrats that's me undies
dot-com / Congrats trip actions
there's a reason half of business
travelers do not use their company's
chosen travel management platform the
booking business travel is ridiculously
outdated time constant time-consuming
and costly if you're frustrated with
this with your company's travel
management program or lack thereof you
need to look into trip actions they take
the pain out of corporate travel with a
complete solution that helps businesses
save it keeps employees happy the reason
trip actions works so well is that it's
the first travel management platform
designed from the ground up with the
road warrior in mind now that's what I
am it's easy to book your company's
business travel from the app or desktop
with 24/7 proactive support around the
globe and incentives for employees to
save on travel expenses companies large
and small see over 90% adoption and save
up to 34% on travel spend when they use
trip actions so get this going guys
companies from lyft to Sara Lee's frozen
bakery trust trip actions with their
business travel reshape your company's
business trouble today with trip actions
go to trip actions calm / Congrats
complete a 30 minute demo with the trip
actions account executive and you'll get
$100 Amazon gift card up by your loved
one some stuff babies but it's this
month only trip actions dot-com /
congrats for his free demo and $100
Amazon gift card trip actions calm /
Congrats so now I'm going to talk about
this oh I got to get those yeah so uh
alright so this guy you may not know if
you're a young baby it was right around
my time in the 80s George Brett was a
was the man he was a great baseball
player on the Kansas City Royals so he
became a coach or some kind of a manager
or something for the for the for the
Royals and there is there is leaked
video and audio of him do you guys know
about this you do right yeah of course
um where he is telling a younger player
oh well you know what let me just play
it for you this guy let me just this guy
let me just start before I even play it
this is the most this is more than
hitting a Grand Slam more than shagging
fly balls more than eating sunflower
seeds waiting on the on-deck circle this
right here this three minutes is the
most baseball thing that has ever
happened here we go it's unreal
stretching George Brett's stretching
okay it's weird to by the way the
managers stretch there's no [ __ ]
reason for it you stand around and tell
people what to do
so he's stretching so now the by the way
the manager dresses up in the [ __ ]
uniform which is so [ __ ] sad
hey that's sad imagine Pat Riley out
there with a [ __ ] Knicks jersey on is
that what you know he was Lakers what
was he
Knicks yeah kind of rights of course
it's Nick you know why it's Knicks look
at Pat Riley couldn't be more New York
hey hey
so [ __ ] going on looks like Pat Riley
is always saying that always on the
percentage so all right all right all
right all right all right this is how it
starts
pardon he says stretch
oh he farts I didn't realize this that's
what he says you hear that fart Wow okay
sweet farts stretching next to a player
[Laughter]
farted
not even I farted do you know how limit
is I'm the ego you have to have on you
to fart and then say farted is is the
ego of someone who wears a robe it's
just unbelievable I [ __ ] my pants last
night and then goes right into this
story okay I [ __ ] my pants last night
dude this is fart
okay okay so now the younger players
like okay and he's just stretching and
he says I did I've had a great meal just
a great [ __ ] meal I had to go a
bathroom so bad
[ __ ] [ __ ] my pants
I wouldn't Audio is kind of weird goes
in and out but it gets better
just listen I'm good twice a year for
that last time you shoot your pants yeah
I was in Vegas a couple years ago just
the honest-to-god truth story I mean I
just I want to set the Bellagio one over
the Mirage for dinner I met some friends
of mine over there went to Kokomo some
great little raw steak house the guy
brings out some fresh crab legs
you guys bring I'm eating them then we
go play gamble a little bit I have a tee
time early in the morning so I said look
I got to get going I'm walking back to
the hotel I get three-quarters the way
out of the lobby and all of a sudden I
go oh [ __ ] and I'm standing here like
this I got my butt pinched so [ __ ] I'm
[ __ ] I can't move all of a sudden you
know felt all right I went just like
this oh yeah you think
take off my leather jacket I'm just
standing there and it's just running
down my leg I got jeans on black bucks
no socks
so I'm walking straight [ __ ] water
then I was then I'm standing outside the
spod kill myself when I call the guy
I said Larry you won't believe this I'm
standing outside the [ __ ] Bellagio I
can't move I got [ __ ] everywhere I [ __ ]
all over myself and Larry's about a 48
waist so he brings me over a pair of
pants and some towels and some towels
and so he then he comes over he meets me
where I'm Stella where I'm standing he
finds the closest bathroom when you go
up the escalator go into the [ __ ] I
can't get the elevator so so he goes and
he finds the closest bathroom in a lobby
of the hotel and then I get in the
escalator and he kind of sounds like he
dropped something so no one gets behind
me dude you know as I go in there he
goes and gets the towel are the guys who
throws it over the [ __ ] the guy who's
talking to him is walking away and he's
following him to wipe off leave my shoes
my shoes my pants everything right there
the towels right there in the stall and
I'm walking barefoot with my shirt and
his pants that are 48 waist through the
lobby like this midnight they're all
walking away most perfect double tapered
[ __ ] I've ever had in my life wait for
it wait for it true story wait for it
wait for it first of all should know you
know it's his team who's by the way
who's the pitchers in this game dude
nothing yo you could hit a grand slam at
[ __ ] with in the bottom of the ninth
to win it behind by three with the bases
loaded and the full an account full and
the that is not more baseball than that
first of all he's wearing bucks with no
socks nothing more baseball than that
dude and a leather jacket dude I can't
believe how baseball this is this is
inside baseball they need to do a
[ __ ] real sports on this bryant
gumbel needs to be like George Brett
former Golden Glove winner a great
manager for the Kansas City Royals a
hometown hero for his for wherever he
grew up did you know he [ __ ] his pants
in the Bellagio and then they just need
to do with a ma did I [ __ ] my pants and
I was running bucks he was the most
baseball dressed person of
all time you were no socks and a leather
jacket who do bro imagine wearing no
socks and a leather jacket [ __ ] my pants
last night that's who deserves to [ __ ]
their pants no Bellagio and the early
tee time nothing is more baseball than
playing golf in the morning dude this
guy is this is unbelievable dude this is
more unbelievable than Darren Chris's
performance in the assassination of
Gianni Versace
this is dude and for the bishop my pants
last night true story who's the pitchers
in this game dude we got a let me break
it down because we just played it so
it's just it's before the game he's
stretching he shouldn't be he's just why
do the managers stretch and wear the
uniform hey guy sad there's the part by
the way he's stretching in front of a
guy the guys faces in his ass and he
farted he says 40 and that's so such a
boss move dude and then the guy walks
away nobody's like they're like okay we
got a play they get or watch the video
it will show it on the video on our
video podcast but like you got to watch
the video because the guys are all
walking away and he's the manager and
the players are like okay yeah cool and
I'm sorry but the parking stall at the
end is all my [ __ ] clothes 148 waste
through the lobby like this perfect
double tapered [ __ ] I've ever had in my
life
true story the pictures in this game
dude also you don't have to say double
tapered [ __ ] the first end is always
tapered because it's common out it's the
second part that is sometimes not
tapered you know perfect double taper
[ __ ] Wow how baseball is it you got to
watch this George Brett [ __ ] thing
god it's so funny man who's the pitchers
in the game tonight
who's the pitchers in this game how old
is George Brett that guy is the man
Golden Globe winner Golden Glove winner
George Brett and let me do it [ __ ]
thing yeah go I want to see the whole
thing go to it no the the the text just
make it bigger you know make it bigger
George Howard Brett born May 15th 1953 a
retired American baseball third baseman
and design designated hitter who played
21 years in Major League Baseball for
the Kansas City Royals took the most
perfect double deckers it did make it
bigger bro I'm not a [ __ ] eagle right
that's 3,150 for I'm Bryant Gumbel did
you know George Brett's 3154 career hits
are the most by any third baseman in
major-league history and 16th all-time
he is one of four players in the Major
League Baseball Association history to
accumulate 3,000 hits but his biggest
feat was [ __ ] his pants with no
socks on at the Bellagio and wearing a
48 waist back to his hotel room so
nobody knew and when he woke up in the
next morning he took the most perfect
double tapered [ __ ] that you've ever
seen and that's a true story
who's the pitchers today
who's the pictures for today's game
printable worst impression of all time
Bryant Gumbel is whiter than a [ __ ]
then powder even though he's black odwar
maverick bankable is he a [ __ ]
rooster dude Bryan come was a [ __ ]
rooster bro one prank come on buck [ __ ]
[ __ ] hey I got a place on Brian come you
know if you're a lot of guys know who
Brian got also also dude Bryant
how you gonna [ __ ] just add a tee to
the end of your name and make it
different
okay get the [ __ ] out of here Bryant hey
my name is [ __ ] palt hey you doing
I'm Paul yeah I'm David Brian is so [ __ ]
to [ __ ] be named Bryant Bryant Callan
real sports okay
bryant also Gumbel dude that guy that
guy's thumb wow that guy [ __ ] they he
you know what I hate when people say
this but this is the truth he [ __ ] um
here's him with Rogan I didn't know
Internet all right I'll just the price
of fuels these days these guys are just
amazing dude the guys who do this are
just amazing they've gotten so big that
you can only appreciate their size from
high above like who are the guys from
[ __ ] some of the guys from the
forensic [ __ ] or wait what's the what's
the now we got to listen to Bryant
Gumbel Gumbel here we got to listen to
his voice here we go why is this on here
we're not remarks in Alabama about what
owners ought to do to players how does
the president's insert looking good
Brian I'm looking up good
into football how's it impacted the game
sir opinion well I don't think you can
totally ignore it but I'd like to
believe that at this point people of
goodwill recognized dude he's a rooster
dude he's - clucking Bryant Gumble
clucks with the military or the flag
yeah it has it's had some effect on the
lessening of interest in the NFL game I
think that's part of it but I think it's
a very small part of it I mean I think I
think there's some bigger issues at work
I think there's some big arrests for the
market a [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] wake up at
6:00 he's a rooster bumper car [ __ ] wake
up it's it's 5:00 there's farm work to
do do you know he wakes up in next to
his wife at 5:00 a.m. and he starts says
I'm Brian Campbell it's time to wake up
it's time to do some farm work and they
just live in Beverly Hills Bock Bock
Bock Bock Bock Bock wake up it's 5:00
a.m. you're burnin daylight bark macaque
talk talk talk real sports-bar [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] taking the shower oh [ __ ] man a
[ __ ] love doing this podcast
goddammit [ __ ] my pants last night for
farted these guys Brian come was looking
good though these guys some people get
really what is it about guys that they
get so much they either really do get so
much better looking when they get older
or they just get so much worse looking
dude who's that guy Greg Gumbel that's
his brother I was gonna say do it how is
that not Brian Gumbel with [ __ ] that
looks like Brian Gumbel Greg Gumbel
looks like Greg Gumbel I don't know is
that apparently does the same thing as
Brian Coble but Brian he looks like
Brian Gumbel
if Brian Gumbel was in the Klumps
Hercules Hercules anyway what was I
saying about the [ __ ] God I don't
know what was I [ __ ] hate when I lose
my train of thought dude I don't
remember it doesn't matter it doesn't
honking matter dude it doesn't
[ __ ] honking matter yeah George Brett
just [ __ ] I loved when I was a kid I
would watch baseball and I loved it and
my dad [ __ ] would would I remember
when the Mets were winning in the 86
World Series when they won my dad was on
the ground just [ __ ] like yes yes yes
you know [ __ ] man
baseball baseball and football and
basketball and hockey those are the
sports men that's it that's all you've
um so I'm gonna do these second reads I
guess where are they oh yeah dissing
goat if you're buying sneakers online
there's more than a coin flips chance
that the shoe you're looking at is fake
I don't know if you know that but it's
true so be careful how can you be sure
it's real goat comm it's the safest way
to buy and sell authentic sneakers
online they're the largest marketplace
in the world for authentic Easy's
Jordans and over 600,000 sneaker
listings they've made the whole process
frictionless and trustworthy they do
this by they do this by only accepting
sellers with the best reputation and by
verifying all sneakers to ensure their
authenticity for buyers I did I bought I
bought Jordans there last time and
they're awesome I got the Union once I
can't they're red and gray ones I love
these shoes every detail is inspected
from the stitching and color to the size
and weight Goat certifies that every
pair of sneakers on their site matches
exact factory specifications find with
over half a million sneakers on the
platform and 10 million users that's 10
million users including my buddy Brendan
Schaub
you won't find better prices for
verified 100% authentic sneakers
anywhere else find the perfect 100%
authentic sneaker at Goat calm slash
Congrats that's goat comm slash code
oops
goat comm / Congrats why don't you write
it here - that's goat comm / Congrats
plus you'll also be supporting our show
but you've got to go right now before
the sneakers you want are gone they go
quick the good ones especially when you
go to go to
/ congrats spelt go8 EECOM / congrats
you get to chew you want cash app I love
this company for doing this here's the
ad for cash app today it goes like this
cash app so yeah so listen man um
Houston I want to talk about I don't
even remember I don't remember I don't
remember you guys do baby voice with
your girl he got two baby boys a girl
dude that's how you start feeling like a
kid you start feeling like you just came
out the home dude
you gotta do baby voice with your girl
man mem bo do you mem Bo or you say
stuff like oh you hooded me or some [ __ ]
that's so gangster wow I have a I have a
stomachache it hurts that's [ __ ]
gangster to do baby voice with your girl
I do it all day long I tell her I say my
stomach hurts and she says it hurts [ __ ]
yeah dude you don't do baby voice with
your girl you ain't [ __ ] dude
I appreciate it if you don't though cuz
that's kind of gangster - nah but dude I
look at but you could [ __ ] I look at
my girl go my stomach holds what yeah
that's gangster Beach
my stomach rules anyway there's another
hockey player with the same name I have
Chris D'Elia
we got a [ __ ] put it we got it
[ __ ] put a squash on that dude
apparently he signed a 1 million dollar
deal the pit next three years which
kinda but does he really know the
[ __ ] I don't know dude but he's
probably [ __ ] 13 so anyway uh yeah
dude there was another there was another
I when I was on myspace myspace was
before a lot of you guys time but when I
was on myspace I tried to get my url
crystally a myspace.com Chris D'Elia and
I ended up getting a [ __ ] myspace.com
dilly-o dilly-o Chris cuz somebody
already had Chris Lee I was like who the
[ __ ] as I could the [ __ ] has Chris
D'Elia and it looked and a guy who had
Chris D'Elia was Chris D'Elia and he's
my age he was in [ __ ] la and a
[ __ ] producer and he was he's my age
and he it was [ __ ] another guy named
Chris D'Elia and this [ __ ] [ __ ]
and he's out there now I think he was a
producer on @midnight or something like
that I've met him a few times but the
first time I ever met him I was at this
place called green door it was a bar
club that my buddy used to [ __ ] run I
used to do the night there like the
promote promoter he was a promoter he's
a promoter and so we we went there and
he and he was like listening this guy at
the bar is like yeah put it on my tab
put it on Chris Delia's tab and my buddy
was like hey man who are you you don't
put [ __ ] money you don't put drinks
on my buddy's tab and he was like what
and he was like you can't put drinks I
don't recognize you don't put drinks on
my buddy's tab and he's like I'm put on
my tag he's like what are you talking
about he's like my buddy Chris D'Elia
he's like I'm Chris D'Elia and he's like
no you're not and he's like yes I am and
he showed him his ID and he was like oh
[ __ ] come here and then he introduced
her to him was like you're the guy with
the [ __ ] MySpace page and and we met
and he's a nice guy it's probably more
annoying for him than it is for me
because you
he's not on TV and [ __ ] and I am and the
God that would be so [ __ ] annoying
being having the same name of another
guy on TV and [ __ ] you're not but it has
a good guy and I saw him at the airport
I've seen him a few different places
anyway there's another hockey near play
a hockey player with our name so [ __ ]
great job we've never got now I got
three of us dude
we can even do all chill play hockey
produce and [ __ ] do comedy maybe we
do a [ __ ] comedy about hockey and you
can produce it he can produce it yeah
anyway that's [ __ ] crazy right you
got guys with your name grow up out
there are the babies out there with some
year and farted [ __ ] my pants last night
true story we have an elder I'm gonna
get into right here we have an elder and
the elder here is at congrats log cab
that's Jake Geoffrey's been out there
with support for a long time and we've
noticed man his personal twitter is mr.
Jake's fifty-three change it but you
know that cuz you're a baby and now
you're an elder dude so thank you for
all you do you keep the word out there
and you spread this cult and we see you
we see you out there so thank you very
much man
it really doesn't go unnoticed and you
are an elder now so congratulations on
your PIN and all that [ __ ] and you'll
get the certificate in the mail coming
tuned because coming soon because one
fire will send it and if he doesn't want
one one fire anyway but also whatever
how much time we got going on 48 minutes
I drink on your mother [ __ ] we have a
guest coming up soon I'm not gonna say
who it is because it's confirmed but we
got a guest coming and it's a big one
it's gonna be the first non family guest
and it'll be March 7th we're gonna do an
extra episode every month with a guest
so we're still gonna keep it real with
the babies because we're wrong what you
see is what you get
right and we're gonna come here and
we're gonna [ __ ] we're gonna talk
about this stuff we're gonna but talk
about robes we're gonna talk about you
I mean the real important issues like
[ __ ] you know how baseball is it to
wear no socks
dude if you were enough yeah that's a
crazy [ __ ] thing to wear shoes some
people were shoes with no socks that's
insane
what do you do when you sweat dude I
[ __ ] traded my car in I got a new car
how annoying is it being at a [ __ ]
car lot just I and I the kind of guy I
am is when I I know people complain if I
know everybody's complaining about
something I like to look for the good in
it because I don't want to be I've like
a [ __ ] thing we're like I don't want
to be like everybody else and so I'm
like yeah it's probably not as annoying
is it you know I just don't I just don't
trust a group of people I don't I don't
trust a group of people anytime there's
a big group I don't I don't trust you
know also if you're a big group of
people you're I think I was talking
about there's an h3 the other day it's
just weird to think all that any time
every well bunch of people think the
same thing it's [ __ ] weird right so
uh that's like anything like religion
[ __ ] you know I know this is a cult
but cults anyway everyone thinks going
like car salesmen they're pieces of [ __ ]
liars whatever so I go in thinking I
know this [ __ ] it people are stupid I'll
get the best of them and and we'll be
friends and [ __ ] like that dude car
salesman I got a buddy who's a car
salesman and he's a good guy so you know
I know good guys do it too and he's oh I
got my car from but the first guy years
ago I got my car from was just a [ __ ]
lying sack of [ __ ] I got this g-wagen I
like the color and they're just I was
just like yeah it's cool you know it's
cool he's like oh it's the best on its
best on the road best-looking car this
and that it's amazing the interiors
amazing I got I was like I got a [ __ ]
like four-year lease as I got what if I
don't like it in [ __ ] two years is
like trade it I'll come in
whatever it's all good fine don't do
[ __ ] I won't I get rid of it no we won't
have to pay I was like all right so I
got it and of course I didn't like it in
[ __ ] two years because the old G
wagons [ __ ] they just don't drive
nice they don't drive well the new ones
do the new ones are amazing but the old
ones don't
it's like [ __ ] it's like a an old
Bronco you know were you just like you
could hurt your shoulder turning the
[ __ ] wheel you know like I got my
tetanus shot I was trying to driving it
was hurting like a [ __ ] by
anyway and he and then I went back to go
trade it in and they were like oh you
will [ __ ] 40 grand on it and it was
like I'm like I'm not paying that [ __ ]
and then he was like and they were like
well then I was like the guy told me he
would do it is like oh he's not here
anymore
like he didn't work there anymore like
these guys are just [ __ ] most of
these guys are just sacks of [ __ ] dude
they're just sacks of [ __ ] they'll be
like yo it's 25 grand you'll just be
like no and they'll be like okay well
then just pay the monthly and you're
like really you're just trying to rob me
from 25 grand it's unbelievable
leave if you're gonna get a car and
they're trying to [ __ ] take advantage
of you leave you know they just don't
they don't give a [ __ ] man anyway I got
a new car and it's awesome just the new
g-wagen it drives so much better
those 2018 and younger and the older I
should say I guess Julian's are not not
worth it man they look they're the
freshest looking cars but they did they
just don't drive right anywhere anyway
let's do Twitter questions or miss
connections yeah me so
we got some from from Miss connections
miss connect gang ping ping pang
Westside remember that [ __ ] Miss connect
gang ping ping pang Westside here we go
oh wow oh wow I never I mean alright so
here we go with the Miss connections CB
here's the [ __ ] you know what a sybian
is it's one of those things that I think
girls sit on and then it's like a dildo
and it [ __ ] vibrates it's like a well
what is a sybian it's like a it's like a
kind of like that right like and you oh
it's a robotic thing that you sit on and
it's got a dick on it right and you sit
on the deck and it like [ __ ] you yeah
right yeah okay that's I thought it was
okay so go back so sibian ryder sybian
ryder dot dot dot where did you go girl
that used to ride my sibian I lost your
number need you back soon or someone
else uh basically just looking for a
sybian rider doesn't give a [ __ ] about
the old one just thrown in or someone
else at the end you know what don't need
to be specific do not contact me with
unsolicited services or offers now what
I'm wondering is why does one fire keep
the text so small but it's what I'm
wondering now it's all good but it keeps
doing it therefore I'm wondering need
you back soon or someone else
I love how a lot of these guys act like
it's pressing like [ __ ] man my wife's
out for three days
need a sybian rider sibian rider sounds
like a [ __ ] old 70s movie with like
you know like Easy Rider
I guess [ __ ] I don't even want to
it's like not worth it it's just too
close to Easy Rider see ya here's
another one Steven I miss you
Hey rydym body Steven I miss coming by
your place and getting you in a better
mood by relieving your stress this is
the 47 year old guy that you used
several times
and then open to other friends a lot of
these guys at the end of their [ __ ]
messages are like you know what I don't
want to leave out the fact that I might
be able to [ __ ] squirt in someone
else let's just be open to everything
and then do not contact me with
unsolicited services or offers you you
you're you don't need to say that you
just said open to other friends yeah so
[ __ ] contradictory a lot of these
guys are country why what what is
relieving stress why is that such a big
thing why can't you just [ __ ] nut why
does it have to be like hey a lot of
these guys are like and I know you work
hard need you need a stress reliever
like dude it's just nuttin ok next one
oh my god dude this [ __ ] title
vanessa with is a long body by the way
vanessa my lyft driver with the
beautiful overbite I kind of like
overbites by the way so it's funny that
this guy's has beautiful overbite you
drove me you drove me and two others
from the east side to the west side on
October 29th this is basically a Montell
Jordan song so far you drove me into
anthems from the east side to the west
side and October 29th I have red hair
and blue eyes you recently broken up
with your boyfriend who wasn't kind to
you and caused your finger to gash what
good wait you'd recently broken up with
your boyfriend who wasn't kind to you
and caused your finger to gash when we
went swimming why did you go swimming
with this person what I think means when
you won swimming I liked your overbite
creepy you liked what I liked that I
liked your overbite I mean when only you
and I were left in the car you asked me
for my number but I was seeing someone
and I had to turn you down but I still
admitted that I found you sexy why would
a guy you told me that you found me sexy
too and I've never wanted to pounce
anyone so wildly in my life not
unromantic real quick why
changed I'm not in that relationship
anymore and if there's any chance that I
could treat you to romance Vanessa I'll
gladly take it hey I want to pounce you
can I treat you to romance do not
contact me with unsolicited service or
services or offers now this guy I
believe because he's not a cheater and
that's very cool usually you think
though if someone's gonna post something
on Craigslist
each eater you know deviant begets
deviant deviancy baguettes deviancy
there's no more ice
Viviane see if we get Steve insane with
an open rope high and above the clouds
in a condo here we go all in caps this
one is good let's start the week happy
so it's almost Monday let's start the
week good just looking for my girl to
have some fun and compensate no men
please normal guy here I mean do not
contact me with unsolicited services or
offers normal guy here normal guy here
let me get on [ __ ] Craigslist and and
and see for a girl there's a girl to
[ __ ] come may have common we're both
bust dude what does NSA good-looking
Mexican guy Long Beach hi any ladies
hosting in Long Beach fret for NSA fun
I'm good-looking Mexican guy do not
contact me once or service or office NSA
what is that national sibian association
national suck in Essos spelled it wrong
Ellen ear where are you maybe Eleanor we
used to meet at the glendale library
when in [ __ ] in 1974 who goes to the
library anymore ah oh my what does that
translate to we used to meet in the
Glendale library I miss your gorgeous
smile and miss your lungs miss your
kisses and
then something in Arabic where did you
go Eleni do not contact me long solicit
services are offers what is this we're
gonna translate what he said in Arabic
or whatever it is what is it oh I love
you cute
hey hey go to the library but it's cute
he loves her Wow made me feel good
hmm who knew one of these craigslist ads
make you feel good anyway who buys a
sybian you know what guy they gotta be a
thousand bucks at least
look guys in the market to buy a sybian
if you have a sybian you better have
four cameras set up you know damn dude
Serbians are crazy I don't understand
that I don't understand it really we're
watching it right now kind of a little
bit we won't put it on her we're not
gonna put an obviously on our YouTube
[ __ ] there 1,200 bucks for a sybian you
can just do it manually and just [ __ ]
get a dildo and just really quickly do
it yourself you do it manually or do you
get a sybian 1200 on Amazon people who
bought this also bought people who
bought this also bought four cameras
[Laughter]
[ __ ] any Twitter questions or we get
packages Sippi and packages dude wow
what do you get with it what do you get
with it so passion purple sibian package
here at cbn.com sibian duck on my thing
so it's a thousand two hundred forty
five bucks product description zoom it
in okay so choose one beige classic
attachments Oh different colors of [ __ ]
I guess okay you get beige chocolate
classic attachments racist to call them
chocolate or purple okay that's if you
want like aliens [ __ ] you slick wid
sibian Lube cube okay got real cute with
the name there slick
you know Lube cube okay two sizes red
riser with two red Stern's stems can't
read because it's too small one stool
power record USA and Canada only
instruction manual step one I mean
really step one
sit on it that's it that's it step one
sit on it step two
bust a nut power cord part of the
package instruction manual very cool
five-year warranty it's part of the
package that's if you [ __ ] break the
deck on your sibian in the first four
years you can get a new one
oh who made a sybian miss I want to talk
to mr. sibian Frank sybian palt sibian
alright well [ __ ] look at this dude they
of course they have to have a lady
instruction pin start instructor if they
had a dude instructor be just way too
creepy on them on the video she's just
like you set up the [ __ ] on your sibian
and the [ __ ] sit on it see ya Dano
neo neo neo neo neo neo sibian calm like
what else would there be what why is
there an instruction video you [ __ ]
put the [ __ ] on the thing and then you
[ __ ] sit on it what's the [ __ ] now
but you know thing Ria's like sit on it
do you know or no there was some Al
Pacino line where he's just like we just
sit on it any [ __ ] are you gonna [ __ ]
yeah you could sit on it I think it's
for I don't know what it's from I think
it's from to for the money with that
Matthew McConaughey more because I
remember [ __ ] laughing so hard
anyway whatever it doesn't matter
alright cool well that's good thanks for
listening everybody download the cash
app for free on the App Store or Google
Play market and two rewards code
congrats get five dollars give five
dollars - times up and download the
crystally app you get to see us live
goofs and all last time we did it and
one fire didn't even record the first
[ __ ] 10 minute so we had to start
over so there's that on the app download
the crystally app in the App Store and
all wherever you get apps do that
support the show by buying mercs you get
this store comp store dot crystally
accom you get the [ __ ] the LEAs
grand-slam you get the [ __ ] wouldn't
make a dent shirt or hoodie and the
babies hoodie it's just [ __ ] cool to
see all you guys out there with the
shows if you're coming to a show sport
that look I see you out there with the
dense shirts and the babies and all that
[ __ ] and the dentist 20/20 I haven't
seen that yet they haven't been
delivered yet but you there pre-order I
gotta get that dent list 20/20 gotta
wear that [ __ ] next year when they
can't start [ __ ] getting the new guys
in office tenantless 20/20 subscribe to
the YouTube channel rate and review me
it really helps on the on that on the
iTunes and all that on iTunes all that
and episodes video episodes go up a day
after the audio podcast check me out on
h3 podcast - I did that yesterday with
those guys they're they're the best you
can watch my episode of communities and
the comedians of the world you can watch
my special man on fire you watch my
special and cordial incorrigible on
Netflix or you can look at white male
black comic on The Comedy Central app
that's it you guys are great st. Louis
I'm coming it was rescheduled I don't
give a [ __ ] what Theo Vaughn says I'm
gonna be there and we're almost sold out
that's over 3,000 people bragging and
I'll be there soon Valley Center or
standing as Albany and overrunning ttan
Cleveland Columbus Cincinnati Lexington
Albuquerque for some reason in Santa Fe
for some reason Phoenix Tucson
Greensboro Charlotte Durham Newport News
Oakland Las Vegas Nevada and if you're
going to see Bryan Callen Bryan Callen
refund your tickets you guys are great
my families and keep on Grand Slam
[Music]